Pretty much everybody has to pay taxes and Grant, with his new Gleaming Glasses
company is no exception. The way that taxes depend on income can be described
by functions. But these are slightly different functions than ones we've seen
before. Let's check them out. First things first, here's a chart showing how a
person's yearly income, determines the amount of money they will pay the
government in taxes where Grant lives. We can see that the tax rate over here,
or the percent of their income that a person will pay the government in taxes,
changes depending on how high the person's income is. The way this works is a
little bit complicated, so bear with me here. Now someone makes under $5000,
please note this entire column is in dollars, so if someone makes under $5000,
their tax rate is 0%. So, they actually don't have to pay the government
anything at all. If someone's total income is between $5,000 and $15,000, the
first $5,000 of their income is set aside and not taxed. Then what is left over
is taxed at this 10% rate. If someone earns between $15,000 and $35,000 total,
then, as with the person in this lower bracket, the first $5,000 of their
income isn't taxed. The next 10,000, is taxed at 10%, and then the rest is
taxed at 20%. If the person makes even more money than this total, then the
amount above $35,000, is taxed at 30%. We can think of this tax rate scaling as
a sort of layering effect. As were counting up the money a person makes, we
don't start by thinking about the total. We start by counting from zero. Once
we get to 5,000, then we start to add our tax rate, and we keep counting up and
up, increasing the rate when we need to.